[Music]
hello everyone how's it going how are
you doing you you're very excited heck
yeah oh this is this your first dream
that your own yeah sure yeah heck yeah
so the perfect stream to break it in -
yeah we're playing some cuphead on
switch yeah yeah and you're gonna be
putting on a cool show for us going for
the the secret bosses yes I'm gonna try
to hit I'll one secret boss I'll - and
then hopefully we can hit aisle three
but I all threes a bit of a sticky one
so yeah that's sweet wool I'm gonna push
right over into the gameplay anyway
because I'm excited to see this yeah I'm
not good at cuphead I was telling you
before we actually even started your boy
is so bad that he just likes watching
other people play it I get to live
vicariously through your skill so I'm
excited for that so okay so we're gonna
do aisle 1 if you guys haven't played
the game then welcome this will be fun
in Aisle 1 you go to the root pack which
is these guys the Botanic panic and you
can do it in two different ways
I'll show you guys how to do the secret
boss but this is a bit of a fun fun
round I like thank ya it's like really
it's a bit trickier than um the regular
mode but I kind of like the challenge of
it all so you're you're here for your
the difficulty for sure oh yeah for sure
so that I I've fought I fought this
before but I did it on simple all I'll
definitely cop that simple is sure I
eventually took out I think maybe two of
the bosses on like a regular one and
then I got too scared to go any further
alright so you'd be potato guy okay
thank you and then you see this giant
onion yeah don't hurt him just be nice
to him
he's so scared and then he's like your
friend okay I'm already so this is not
okay so this is like the carrot boss but
with a little bit extra yeah a little
bit extra a lot of carrots a lot of a
lot of fun so do you have to beat both
of them so you have to beat the red
angry radish man as I call him okay
first and then you can beat the carrot
guy gotcha
so on the first on first try I believe
in you I know you can do it
I'm excited
ooh hit that special gotta get that
special I think it makes things a lot
easier if you hit a special definition
okay so everything's fine this is all
completely under control 100% calculated
totally building nothing nothing says
right this first one of the day
its first getting warmed up the easy
part it's just that last part that's
different and it's really fun if you've
played the game a lot because it's it
provides a different challenge it
prepares you for you know the DLC that's
supposed to come out this year yeah and
it's it's kind of like rejuvenates the
fun you can also play smug man I chose
cuphead so we change it up if we want to
oh yeah I don't hurt him he's so scared
yeah I I love how expressive and
everything that's already been said
about how how great the art style is in
this game
just i'll save everyone the trouble and
not say it again it's a very beautiful
game the soundtrack is phenomenal yeah
Bob Jones crime box night Johnny
Derwin are you guys in the chat how are
you doing I hope you're having a good
Monday hello pop Jones asked funny
murdering everything today I'm gonna try
not to do any murders all right so third
time's the charm
that's what they say it's it's yeah I
mean this this game is designed to be
difficult it's it's challenge so you
said that you haven't played it boy want
to I've played it I just there's the
whole point between doing a thing doing
really well and then having the the boss
card come up at the end where it tells
me you've done 75% of damage no we're
not doing that County now third time is
a try this is the real 33% the funny
part is is that when you actually hurt
him you feel bad yeah now she's right
you know that he's gonna like smile and
be happy about you just don't want to
hurt him yeah that potato is a shot a
warm out of its mouth yeah
nobody touch him I'm George hello Jordan
welcome hi Jordan ha new take to
discover the secret bosses so what what
is the the story with the secret bosses
like fill me in on their character
bosses that they wanted to add before
but they just didn't have a place okay
and then I cannot I'll see this I'm
gonna ask you the hard-hitting questions
while you're trying to concentrate
that's that's how how it all gets played
out we we can wait for the story till
after year you're done fighting that
actually is a not a good setup exactly
Bob John says it doesn't count until you
actually get to the box so we didn't
even have it's all good
resting hello how's it going yeah this
weekend was so weekend was a real doozy
for for people who loved kind of cool
nerdy things here we go third time's the
charm
doing it anime I did watching an anime
thing oh I can so I can explain the boss
thing now okay sure
yes a lot of these bosses were things
that they wanted to add during the game
but they didn't have any like reason to
add them okay and then then they just
implemented them in the new update oh
yeah which is pretty cool so this isn't
all the different versions it's not yeah
no it's not a switch exclusive you can
get this in any we're just doing this
which was because it's the newest one
yeah
these carrots that [ __ ] me yeah the the
floating carrots everything everything
else is uh it's gonna game so for not
posting spoilers Natalia's friend game I
know that our enemy to our entertainment
team worked very very hard to like cover
as much of a sense that would be our
urgent work team worked really hard to
cover as much of the stuff as they could
and also not give away things I know
that there were some other places that
straight up put spoilers like in their
titles in their subheads
mats I'm not gonna call anyone out sorry
don't sorry but but you know I I know
that our team it really cares about that
kind of stuff in like even in the office
this morning
like people were already the censor like
whatever we were going to talk about for
people who still hadn't seen it yet so I
make sure that everyone gets chance to
its enjoying it I honestly think that
sorry going back to all the tough good
thing I honestly think that the blue
finger gun would actually be better for
this because it provides more damage oh
but it's like you want to hit all these
guys so I'm gonna switch it up a little
bit it's the it's the shotgun status
where you you just kind of hit hit
everything yeah you want to hit them
with this and then when the carrots show
up there you go got it
heck yeah and then when the carrots show
up then you want to switch over
everything just super easy actually you
know with comedy kind of learned how to
strategize and change up your weapons
and it kind of took me till the fifth
try to realize the blue actually hits
him harder but you want to him when he
does the psychic third eye type of thing
and then change it to the eight spread
when you have to care
so these are the strategies that I
definitely never picked up on and then
use your specials as many times as you
can now move it perfect yeah there you
go that was a quick tip on somebody
who's uh this kind of get it yeah that's
all good so that's the the first the
first secret boss down that was the
first one um now I'm just gonna quickly
go through a couple other bosses cool
cool
we're gonna go through the one that
looks like Betty Boop does that Flynn
one we're gonna go through the flower
guy and then what other one oh and then
I'll try to do a pacifist mode if you
guys don't know what that is I can
explain it to you guys and then and then
we can beat King dice our friendly
neighborhood King dies oh yeah and if
you want to learn more about what went
into the design of that boss well this
is the great primal thing we can do you
should check out audio logs most recent
episode which is actually if you haven't
watched any of our audio log stuff we've
got one with Korey bar log on god of war
and we had one on cuphead in the design
of King dice you should definitely check
it out it's really cool to kind of see
what goes into the creation of this kind
of stuff and getting walked through it
by the people who made it yeah check it
out I think it's really cool yeah yeah
especially if you haven't played cuphead
it's kind of an if you haven't played it
it's really interesting so tiny tiny
mode but yeah I just I think it's really
obviously especially cuz you never get
to really hear that stuff yeah see get
if you got a few of em but that did it
did they do it though did they go did
did the actually spoiler thing I
actually I tried not to look too much
either way so I'm actually kind of
asking actually for real if you didn't
see anything but as far as I know it was
pretty good
what's this um are we playing on Daniel
wants to know we're playing on the
Nintendo switch hope entertainment
console switch switch switch yeah so
we're gonna just to reiterate we're
going to go through the game but
whenever we hit a secret boss we're
gonna do that instead of like the
regular road so the next ones in aisle 2
with what's-his-face the genie and then
aisle 3 it's with salad stage play which
is gonna be the tougher one I don't
really think I might I might not get to
her we gonna try heck yeah
turn has a question you might be able to
answer yeah much better than I I could
we ever fix the quick weapon swap
exploit for the final boss or in the
final boss exploit I actually don't
I don't know actually because the only
thing I know that they changed was or
like that they fixed involving weapons
was the charge because the charge is
super overpowered if you were ever able
to get to it um but if you were ever
able to buy it so I don't know you
definitely should check the patch notes
that are honesty NBA charts page for all
of those questions because that will
definitely help you very fair
well this game just got on my switch
loving every second everyone's having a
good time with cuphead I should I should
try to get back into it you know yeah
holy I think I mean it's only $20
yeah it's just I keep getting
sidetracked like I'm still like very
deep in more combat just there's so much
going on yeah definitely that that's fun
it it would be if they fix this hours
I'm still struggling
I tell me more I I finished like
90-something towers in the last week and
I don't know how I've retained my sanity
at all yeah is there not completely
beside everything that we're actually
focusing on the street there we're so
frustrating I just I I love like the
actual like Mortal Kombat gameplay when
you're actually doing a regular fight
but those towers are just oh now would
you say they're too much like I bet
sometimes or what you say well I think
cuphead is design in a way that you're
meant to be able to beat it it's
definitely like a challenge but there's
some stuff in in the towers and more
combat that almost seems like it's
impossible like to be able to finish a
tower that I saw yeah you you have to
finish it with a flawless victory not
getting hit and then there's poison gas
that slowly takes away your health so
you have to have probably two things one
to make it so that you don't take damage
from the poison learn another one to
heal you yeah cuz you're inevitably
gonna take damage otherwise you won't be
able to finish the tower you got to do
that for like three fights huh either
way I'm excited to see what they changed
and I want that update to come out I'm
sitting on like two million coins to
spend two million yeah help me please
please lift this curse son love to Ben
yeah but anyway it was really fun
playing during the community Friday last
week because I got to play the game for
just what it is
yeah yeah that's a good time we got that
contract collecting those Souls yeah we
got it
easy-peasy that was the second try which
I felt yes okay so for this guy if you
guys don't know what pass mismo means in
running guns which there are a couple
you can actually you actually play those
rounds without shooting anything so I'm
gonna try to do it with this one just so
that you guys can see like a different
route that you guys can take you know
they try to be friendly you know they're
like don't murder everything yeah it's
it's a good way to be sure the people
the devil wants you to murder
exactly green for you thank you hey any
time thanks is this a true story
you betcha 100% factual no lies detected
also sign know if you are playing cop
head or you want to learn something
about it the best thing to own is the
smoke bomb it is your saving grace so
you get a whole bunch of iframes new you
teleport as long as you don't shoot
anything here at your set yeah pretty
much more comments which is surprisingly
good yeah it it looks like it runs
pretty well in I mean obviously have a
bit of a graphical downgrade the only
problem I have is how much stuff is
inaccessible when you're offline but
that's also a problem with all the
versions of the game like you can't
check the Crypt you can't do the towers
you can't do like maybe a third of all
the options available
c90 towers yeah I meant like
90-something towers and Mortal Kombat
for this week I'm sorry let myself die
on that one there are three secret
bosses Bob Jones three bosses oh no
you're good you're actually talking
about which I'm just going off on a rant
about Mortal Kombat no please it's
really fun I will hi we're here to talk
about cuphead and world combat and how
I'm missing that anyway you guys come
here and I'm like livestreams because
it's more of just a chance to kind of
hang out while we've got like a cool
game happening
yeah Mortal Kombat still a thing but
yeah it's I meant like 90-something
towers I I mean like the point six
percent of the leaderboard so I'm
getting that scorpion skin that's
agreeing really excited about that sorry
I'm listening
oh no you're good I'm getting caught up
in what you're doing cuz you're doing is
much more interesting oh the guy really
bugs me I'm not sorry bauxite says hey
buddy don't me asking how long have you
been in the industry for maybe like ten
years I haven't really paid attention to
much Blake I worked for Destructoid
doing live streams for like five or six
years there and then I went to IGN for a
couple of years and now I'm here yeah
yeah for a bit
I'd have to like actually look at the to
run some numbers and get back to you
yeah but I feel like it's pretty close
to 10 years this deal is the new DLC for
cuphead Chow is playable or so I mean
that three people like hop head at the
same time Eric's got some questions
about the DLC you know that's a really
good question because because it would
be very cool if you could play if you
could play all three but I'm I'm not
sure I know you could play I know you
can play too but I really don't know
okay
probably the thing that gets answered
when the DLC actually I really hope so
also I want to do a quick shout-out to
that the name of that DLC because it
the acronym for it is just DLC I forget
what the actual name is that's it it's
like that's brilliant I didn't really
even realize until I was talking about
it with somebody and I went what the
heck yeah yeah that's brilliant
we're so we've already fought one yeah
we fought one but I'm just doing this
because they're done so that's how you
do past this mode you don't have
anything just kinda yeah also this game
is not available for ps4 it's available
on Mac PC Xbox and we're on our way to
the second secret boss now yeah we're
heading there I just need to do one more
sorry about that
it's a Scott it's one of those things
where I wish we could just immediately
hop - oh yeah yeah it's good to kind of
show the process of like going from one
to the next the next I mean yeah we got
to fill up an hour and a half with
sweets streaming content Oh an hour and
a half all right I'm here for it yeah
we're already coming up on the first
half-hour like times flying by
all right we're gonna do the flower one
this one's my favorite
I like him yeah yeah they're animated
really well I remember seeing like a
like a feature documentary or something
on how how the animated him or something
it looked really cool so all traditional
2d just pretty cool does he used to do
that well he's got that sweet dance move
- well we just secret boss always heck
yeah do you know me my boy
someone asked is there a reason you're
doing passive mode well there's really
no reason to do it except for if you
want to get so I mean aisle three you
can actually meet this turtle who says
you know there's a different way of you
know being running guns and if you do
you get this really cool black and white
mode so the whole thing instead of being
in color will be in black and white so
it's really more if you just kind of
want to be a completionist you can get
that but if you you know you could you
just go on and murder everything it's
totally fine whatever whatever your
agenda is I'm cool with it I just kind
of wanted to do it because you know
where it's a flexible
it does yeah flexing my skills main
wants to or says that if you play this
game and they know that this isn't a
secret boss this this isn't where the
second secret boss no no this is just a
flower that we aim to work it's on the
way yeah we're on the way there oh no
this is terrible
we do this now now oh that makes
everything so blurry oh crime wants to
know what your your top played games of
this year are while you're in the middle
of this boss fight definitely feel free
to answer no okay my top my top played
games this year definitely cuphead
that's not a I mean you know I've played
a lot of switch games but I've been
playing a bit of Apex because I have
some friends who really want me to play
I've been playing some smite cuz I'm
just an old-school smite fan but yeah
it's a lot of like Mario Kart you know
she's crafted world oh heck yeah no I'm
a switch fan yeah I watch a lot of
horror movies you want to tell them you
want me to tell you about that go for it
someone asked do you hate yourself cuz I
mean your play cuphead you know no I
don't that's that's the difference like
when you're when you're good at it it's
not it's not like a masochistic thing
okay really quick though there's a lot
of times I think I played in the in
aisle two there's a dragon that you'll
meet today and I've never been more mad
at this this dragon I think I played
eight hours to try to beat him and my
hand cramped up - oh man and then the
only way I beat him was by playing Kenny
Loggins danger zone that's fair
[Music]
now we're on the way the second island
we did it yeah we did it second island
and then yeah I'll show you guys oh yeah
animation hot dog hot dog this is our
grandpa
he gave us some magic powers and we're
just ramped up
I do but you'll never get close to the
devil listen we got to do the right
thing
I can't believe this are we are we type
of people who will do the right thing oh
no I've been told I'm on the alignment
chart I'm chaotic trash so probably not
I'm chaotic evil - this is gonna go well
all right so let's go to the second boss
the second boss is located here but
before we can go there we have to talk
to this guy because he'll provide us
with a different upgrade to the airplane
so now you have bombs so you can switch
your weapons between bombs and gun heck
yeah which makes this a lot easier but
it doesn't mean that the last round
isn't going to be yeah yeah painful lit
wants to know how I feel about days gone
I haven't played it yet but from what
I've been hearing and seeing the the
gameplay seems like it's alright but
some of the writing and maybe the main
character aren't the best I haven't
played it yeah I I'm not gonna say
anything definitive until I actually get
my own hands on it but what I have heard
and seen but I'll give it a go yeah I I
probably play it just cuz um you know I
love the idea of zombie zombie games but
you know I I just haven't touched it yet
so I really don't want to give my
opinion on it
see it's a game that seems like it was
definitely designed to like fit right in
the middle of a Venn diagram of like
Sons of Anarchy fans and Walking Dead
fans
I don't really watch either of those
some kind of like cool motorcycle
zombies I guess but it looks cool I mean
I like to play games I like games yeah
so okay first first round was easy I
personally feel like the first round
could either go one or two ways for you
you can either get like a really good
orangey with the swords or you can end
up with what I got which is not fun or
you end up with the medium not painful
one which is the cats but yeah Oh Irish
game wants to know if either us have
played destiny too I have way too much
oh here we go
so when you're in this next round
instead of ending up in your big form
you just go in your little tiny airplane
mode and he like you know does this
little psychic thing and super boss oh
hey his name's little pup head he's
adorable but he's also a douche
I believe it no there's a lot happening
I was just the first try it this secret
boss so oh man oh yeah so this is a good
one you basically have to hope that you
get this one shot his entire skull away
yeah
persona 5 warrior game coming to switch
yeah I'm excited for that
I love Musso games I'm like the only
person the world is excited for a
persona moose
yeah I'm not I'm not a big fan of
greaser games
I'm not I just find them so annoying
it's fair they're the very very mindless
but I think that's also why they kind of
appeal to me yeah I mean like it'd be
nice to play a mousou game after like
the hours and hours that you've played
oh yeah that at this point I'm just
looking for any excuse to not look at
more combat towers I should probably
back and finish yoshi's crafted more
because I love that game it's so
delightful how many secret bosses are
there do you know three second oh I
didn't do it I didn't do it oh that's
big okay so this is a different one
that's big
this best big pup head this is a
different way of doing it but we're not
going to do that when we do that the
tiny one I was just so focused you get
into the flow of just doing the fight
that you're still doing the fight well
you get so used to doing the fight that
you've gotten like that you do often you
know that you kind of realize oh yeah
there's a secret way of doing things
yes this does work on all systems also
on clickbait title there's nothing click
maybe about this title at all no we're
trying to get to all of them but you
know to get to all of them you got to
really do the process yeah you can't
just snap your fingers and be there yeah
this thing this isn't a Danice moment
where you'd be like you know what
imagine I want to play all the levels of
cut cut immediately snap your fingers
yeah yeah master kid says acting is
really bad in days gone they're kind of
bad in days god I don't want to misquote
huh that's one of the things that I've
heard a lot about it
the main thing being any time deikun
runs up on a nest he like he always has
to like just smell a nest around here
like just every time any eq always has
to inhale or breathe into the microphone
that they recording with it's just
that guy much I don't like I don't like
it at all I think I have to beat him
first - which is not Musel games are ok
but the very repetitive sir yeah they're
very repetitive like as a person who
loves those kind of games I'd have to
admit their faults like it's it's a very
easy thing to take knowledge there are
times a charm well I just realized I
should be using my bomb on the little
guy oh yeah I don't know why I'm just
like saving it there's no reason for it
it's one of those things really like
I've got this and I don't want to like
go overboard yeah well it's kind of like
I want to use it for the main guy but
it's like hold on
you need to you'd be the little guy
first little pop head yeah so sometimes
people complain talking people still
complain yeah I love talking
protagonists when they're good
I love silent protagonists when the rest
of everything else is good I like I like
them I'm good with either way I have a
very high tolerance for garbage though
so I'm kind of excited for whatever
comes
[Music]
is Deacon st. John more or less
pretentious the Jackson Sons of Anarchy
I haven't watched Sons of Anarchy so I
can't I can't speak to that okay cool
let's do this yeah I'm gonna oh yeah and
the other thing whenever he picks it
when he's picking up stuff saying needed
this but also uh but he he says
something like nothing like scrapper or
something they're like aw scrap this
looks really difficult it's all good
it's just so much in that third round
you're are you kidding me yeah the
between the the revolving pyramids and
the extra puppet in the actual boss and
you have to beat the puppet first before
you can be genie guy which just says a
lot yeah although I'm really loving this
the swords
[Music]
what game you wish wasn't switch I'm
playing a lot of games in a lot of
places I can't think of a game off the
top of my head that I'd like to take
anywhere like I can play Grim Fandango
on my switch anywhere that's wild to me
like I remember a few years ago when Tim
Schafer was like yeah you can't find
Grim Fandango anywhere you might as well
just pirate it like that's that's crazy
talk but I'm really glad that now I came
like I've bought the game three times
you know
the gamer I'd like to take on the go
this is anything right we didn't pick
anything I personally would love to have
Sly Cooper because I think I just really
like that game I liked all four of them
I think they'd be really fun to take on
the go but all you have is all we have
it is on PC herb not PC PlayStation yeah
and the Vita 2 which is gold but you can
only play it come here guy Vita means
life yeah Vita is life waiting for that
Vita to announcement were you supposed
to even go that's good that's good
that's not good
destiny 2 on this which put World of
Warcraft on the switch it's it's who I
if I knew I'm seeing you're just
watching and I still don't know I'm
trying to think of like the best of
route to go or where to put myself when
the pyramid hates me when it's a lot
it's all good third time's the charm
here we go
like decompress with anger see picked up
the DMC series for PlayStation where's
that stuff resents which though yeah
like a character action game would be a
really good thing for the switch I know
we're getting that like weird platinum
time cop game at some point time cops I
forget what it's called but it looks
really cool be into that we've got
Bayonetta and one and two gonna get
three on there eventually eventually
which may be the closest thing to this
might not be if we're talking about
future games and be cool to see Beyond
Good and Evil that'd be really that
would be pretty cool
I don't do but then again I'd rather
have that on like all you guys cover me
once in clickbait on the title explain
to me what you think click rate is
because I don't think that means what
you think it means before I move on also
someone asked if we watched users last
night and do we like it this book Wow so
I'm one of the weird people like I I
kind of enjoyed it
I like the way that the whole episode
screamed I don't want to get too much
into like spoilery stuff but
it's cool to see that kind of idea
actually we're gonna get cuphead for
free I don't know if you can maybe feel
like loops forward and down right it's
command & Conquer would be great on this
okay I'm gonna try something different
I'm gonna try to do the corner I'm gonna
try to do the corner of the screen
around that area maybe that'll do
something I don't know I really don't
I'm trying to think of the type yeah
where do I go in hora wants to know do
you know where the singer bosses are I
want to find them too so the first one
is on the okay so when you first start
the game there's a era called the root
packing and it's platonic panic and then
you should be able to get the last bone
the last the last little secret boss
from the boss which I called the angry
radish you just don't hit the onion
don't make the onion cry if you make an
onion cry you've gone too far
they go back then you have to start over
but when he becomes your friend that's
when the Super Bowl comes out thank you
so much and then this one we're doing
right now yeah so basically you turn
into a little airplane when dungeon or
whatever the genie scans you and he's
like oh you're little then let me
introduce you to my little friend
putty little pup head who's terrible
okay so I'm thinking I can just go here
and kind of like angle it so I hit him
okay okay okay and then just kind of
hope that things work out well and I
don't think they are but you know what
yeah try different strategies joints
[Music]
yes sorry the beating was for free and
I'm not happy with it I'll pay for it
yeah please I'll be up this
oh here's the cat cats are pretty good
but I don't know if I like this setup
it's a lot to look at yeah
so-so with baby covet go to the corner
but I think I have to kill baby pup head
first because I couldn't kill okay I
couldn't kill dango I couldn't kill just
opal
I couldn't kill the giant carrot without
killing the without killing the angry
radish first so I have to kill baby pup
head before I kill the gene mate yeah
thank you
I think that might be how it's set up is
it's just like a an extra thing that
pops up yeah but it's like I can't
hey it's possible it's Monday it's also
I walk in there like hey you want do
cuphead yes
I didn't let me get crazy there you go
Wow heck yeah did it now thanks so much
hey yeah for sure we're happy to help
you any way we can
sorry given such advice aisle 2 is a
learning experience is what I've learned
yeah it's it seems like there's a lot
going on yeah I'm trying to think of
like what would be the best okay the
best way to do it but it just kind of
seems like you should just keep all your
health and you know tell will talk to
you know where get out of here the exits
this way get out of here now I
understand why cuphead is a game that
makes you go crazy mad yeah it's it's a
challenge I mean you know the other
thing I could do is do just the regular
level and move on yeah we could do that
do you want me to just keep going guys
hey cuz at this point you're I'm gonna
start hey you know that this is a cup
and experience this is the pure
unfiltered entire I mean hey all real
big fish in in blink-blink crumber you
listen to scour music
Scott's gone ever died
[Music]
I think bio mutant so ever come out the
by mutant I hope so because the game
looks pretty fun yeah
those boss makes me mad
it's more it's not it's not even the
regular boss it's the it's the secret
boss it's just a little puppet I just
William wants to know how many deaths
you've had by the first time you
finished the game first time they were
at 700 and they did like they're shocked
emoji it's a kind of the first time I
don't even I'm probably around the same
range to be honest Joe I'm at like seven
hundred deaths I meant like the third
boss so but beating the game just kind
of provides you you don't have you zero
deaths at that point you're eternal
you've done you've done did it you
nailed it if I can't beat the secret
boss I'm just gonna go and do the
regular mode so that we can just get to
aisle three
oh heck yeah that's totally for it we've
at least shown this one yeah and where
you can get it and I can find it and if
I can't beat up I'm sorry I just want
like I just want to crush his little
head at this point technically we've got
we've got three secret bosses this stage
play one is really fun we're playing for
an hour and a half's and you're you've
got like twenty minutes left of this
like half hour segments you'd keep going
for 20 more minutes on this guy oh for
sure no no I don't like okay it's like I
can't I don't even realize that he's
shooting around yeah he's shooting
around the circle okay yikes yikes
just sniped you no strings attached
what's your favorite boss level design
it's
what's his name BB clown
I guess the bead births I like him he's
cruel and I'm glad he doesn't have a
secret super boss because I would be
enraged yeah so yeah listen to Scott
startup before was like yet oh man heck
yeah
chronic crime is just Karma's reminding
me that we've already connected between
with our love of Scott music heck yeah
Scott's cause the music for the people
it brings everyone together alright
let's do this I'm just gonna do the
regular road guys I apologize we ready a
big pup head instead of little pup head
because it's still still a puppet though
technically it's a pup head it's just if
you go and do the third one and you
actually finish it you're gonna have to
come back to this like you oh yes yes
yes yes
expand me standing for life ah we found
it the life it's here it's the puppet
come here pup pup head
see this guy is so nice this seems much
more manly
I played this once with Jared
moldenhauer oh and I tried to save him
and that I died yeah go away go away
little guy see no longer the pub head
only just Jeannie and I still AM George
dangerous yeah I went for the dangerous
route but look how close I was that that
would make someone yeah does that make
yeah that would make me probably stop
playing for a bit
I'll just grind thank you and if anyone
else is having a very good time watching
the stream you should definitely
subscribe to so you don't miss a single
show we do every weekday at 11 a.m.
Pacific we're here hanging out and
playing video games and then I get to
promo the show that I do every Friday
with John Luke where we play games with
you guys if you want to step up and beat
us up in Mortal Kombat that's the place
to do it
we also play all the games play Halo
just anything we can play with you guys
sorry you're good if we had like sure
brought like stress reliever like
mechanism where you go like a stress
ball
[Music]
the best bet says the subscribed not
pulling a Borat joke definitely a little
out of date that's alright
hey you don't have to subscribe if you
don't want it and that's your choice be
sure to watch the audio well definitely
check out the audio logs episode for
company if you like koppad yeah there's
a thing called thick mug men who set me
up for that
this DMK stream that's alright crime we
might be doing it again this week just
just there's like nothing else coming
out box i wants to know if Eric's
beating the secret bosses I don't know I
don't know if Eric's beaten cuphead I
don't know if I've asked him about that
Pablo says do the bomb after the genie
stops moving is game now is that with
the like with regular pop head or after
or with low puppet there might just be
like a general tip I mean we could do it
party I need him to stop laughing I'm
gonna
changing days gone review and I'll
subscribe maybe the game just not good
to the person who played it that's fine
maybe you need to change your opinions
about reviews you just accept it like if
if you like it that's cool like don't
don't let someone else's opinion like
drag it down don't play it because or
don't buy it because someone's review
says they don't like it you know
everyone likes different games some
people don't like cuphead I like how
good oh [ __ ] Queen Shrek - this Friday
we're not playing Shrek - you might
place trying to you know a game you
should play that strict either stretch
super smash or strike super party okay
basically the do a history of Shrek
games get shrekt live on there's so many
Shrek games that are based on Mario
Party yeah Smash Bros or I think there's
a Kart one to get stretched wreck karts
I mean it's like back in the day when
they wanted oh my goodness they wanted
struct it'd just be a part of everything
DJ comes in with the the hard truth and
k-11 towers are more frustrating units
you know what feel that yeah that
probably feels that a lot I feel that
why but the problem is I keep running my
head into the wall for MK towers I had
to take a break from them you know
here we go let's do it I'm not gonna do
a little puppet yeah that's fine
hey I'm here for I was having a good
time watching puffy emotional support
I play strong I played a strong
emotional support role I'm here for it
down hole man get Shrek in the New
Avengers movie oh heck yeah
can't believe Shrek was the one that
stopped Thanos and saved the world of
course he did shrek shrek is shrek is
love shrek is life i can't believe the
last line that shrek said before he
snapped his fingers at the infinity
glove on or get shrek anyway please stay
tuned for more of my fake spoilers for
take a second to kind of refocus and get
everything back together you did it
though I know but I didn't do a little
puff head and I'm gonna I will this is
like that odd
on my Twitter it this means that we can
move on to the third secret boss and if
you if you knock that one out easily
we'll just come back to this one and
keep going so again we'll get all of
them the third circuit boss comes after
I beat the candy lady the clown lady the
clown guy the dragon guy and the bird
guy so maybe we'll get to the third one
eventually it'll happen you know the
journey the Sugar Land shimmy I'm ready
for it
yes get shrekt yikes yikes the fact that
you can play this at all in talk and
interact at the same time is insane to
me
William giving you big props for it
thank you we keep asking you the
hard-hitting questions when you're in
the middle of doing the most difficult
place
so really quick with this guy it's all
about orangey honestly you get like this
is like the easiest boss out of all of
them just don't hit don't get hit by the
gumballs and yeah he's dead already
dang but the hardest one I think for
this one is it's a cupcake man
someone asked why don't you play two
player give Ben the controller you don't
want to do that
but you don't play I tried to player
I'll try a boss after this just to show
you how like how bad I am but I also
think if you do co-op I'll drag you down
no look I actually because I think they
get like more health shiro mad does it
say like if you ever get that angry
restore your head it's a heck of a thing
[Music]
it's fine this is living on the edge
no but we had the best orangey I can't
let that go oh just the first try this
is fine I do know the muffin man who
lives on Oh God who knows
dress I don't even know if I'm allowed
to disclose that I signed an NDA with
another man
oh shoot oh shoot indeed that's can't
lose that relationship no I get free
muffins it's not a flappy waffle yeah is
a flappy waffle a little bit butter I
didn't eat breakfast this morning in us
Oh Oh little worse once
oh yeah do you know how many co bosses
were added it's only three three but the
only three that we know of you know you
never know with mr. diem in the HR they
always like they could provide more
bosses or stuff that there's just so
many things that they do on with their
free update you never know yeah yeah but
yeah like I said you just check the
patch notes you know like that little
jelly bean at the sword Oh disgusting I
know you don't like no I'm not about
candy corn I feel it I feel like there
was someone who who admitted to liking
candy corn in the office once but it was
only once oh wow
so don't know sorry bumped into you
they're trying the best they're like
running out they want to help this game
is the wrong game to play while you're
hungry yeah this round for sure the
candy corn brought me back into the
normal a little bit though so candy corn
can't go reminded you that there are
better things out there yeah
I find I get last time it was like past
[Music]
[Music]
the little jellybean with the knife is
my spirit animal just feel that uh yeah
me too I'm the pink one that's like I
will kill you and then he goes still a
little genie and he's like hey stop it
from says they don't like candy in
general if you can't eat it don't wanted
to just taste sugar
hey that's fair it's actually probably
better anyway because they don't have to
worry about eating too much candy
bauxite says they've never had candy
corn before you're living in a better
world man I'm gonna push this anti candy
corn agenda real hard we don't like
candy from here
I prefer ring pops oh dang or Jolly
Ranchers anything hard candy not candy
corn it is kind of like a weird like
candy corns got an odd texture to it and
it's it's really weird-looking so it's
like a different kind of sweet just I'm
not into it
[Music]
should I do a running gun should I do a
the clown or should I do the bird what
do you guys feel like because at this
yeah no I remember people having I also
do the dragon if we're feeling dangerous
so yeah gummy bears are your favorite
hell yeah very nice blue Drago saying
that candy corn is the best you weigh up
even though I'm pushing the anti candy
corn thing if you say you like I like
candy corn occasionally oh if you could
say it's the best I guarantee you
they're probably at least ten other
candy things you might like more than
candy
oh yeah been 20/20 my candy come on come
on anyone say that about Salah is a lot
to do gone candy corn daddy here you're
not welcome oh these are great
I love channels also loves candy corn so
yeah I can understand people saying I
like it but say it's the best I mean I
want to otherwise I don't want to battle
anyone play take it to the world combat
take it to taste comment they decide the
fate of candy corn was very close the
soundtrack is on Spotify it's a good
call-out from freezer you can also get
oh well you didn't get a sorry no sorry
there's a lot of you can get this like
really cool vinyl that there that I am
8-bit is bit bringing out that would you
can get it on I am 8-bit and it's just
like seek or not secret but like
different songs that were using cuphead
or like best of songs from top pad yeah
I bought it immediately heck yeah I
couldn't pocket is Disney um yeah 1930s
Disney or you know a lot of that time is
definitely it's reminiscent of Disney
and
the fleischer and all those amazing
artists that made movies that we don't
see often enough anymore so yeah good
all right so what'd you say clown I said
clown some people are saying go for get
to a dragon so okay dragon time yeah I
need to change to the dragon so if you
want to just immediately go to the
dragon you just kind of well first off
you can talk to her because she'll tell
it she'll ask for a shortcut nearly what
kind of shortcut and you just kind of go
past the bird around the mountain oh and
you keep going keep going and Oh bingo
that's uh that's wild yeah also I got a
coin because I did three Perry's yeah
you know coins if you talk to a lot of
these NPCs they either give you tips or
things that you can get um a lot of it
is money hmm
money is pretty good I don't get that
get that bread all right
I use the lobber on this one and the
8-bit one but normally the lobber is the
best one okay I also just realized I did
not use I did not put in my second
special the second special is the best
one for this one which makes you
invincible but yeah oh god I'm having
PTSD dang
[Music]
set.you says we should show off action
games this is a pretty action again yeah
we play all sorts of games though if
this isn't enough action for you
eventually maybe later on this week
we'll mostly it's the right type of
action that was out screen that was
off-screen I call shenanigans okay this
guy oh yeah because it kind of blocks
your your view of it does the switchport
have any other differences their levels
in the PC version I think it's the same
thing right yep okay alright bite me
bite me Joe it's raining Oh No okay
before before I actually do this uh I
made one big mistake which is you you
really shouldn't use the first special
your best bet is to use special - which
makes you invincible that's why I did
the mausoleum first oh heck yeah um but
so this one is an energy beam which is
great but you really wanted to use your
invincibility for that third round but
that's just the tip so tall yeah I mean
it would've been cool if I beat it with
the special little special one mm-hmm
but after eight hours of doing it you've
realized that that's that's not the way
you want to do it no yeah that's fair no
although fun fact when they were
animating grim matchstick the third
heads are all they're not all a part of
the body they all like he had to animate
them individually
so shout outs to all of the animators on
pub head because that's a lot of time
and effort and also a lot of hand-drawn
whoa gosh got right up in his face if if
you do it'll have to be like a like a
MIDI or something I'm listening to
chromatic music and also oh that's an
arcing shot using the boom rimshot for
the Dragons they can concentrate more on
just doing the jumping that's what yeah
I think that's just me though so this is
just so you can get up in their face
while you do this so you get anymore
yeah
oh alright this guy does this Oh No
hold on a dragon doesn't need to turn
into a flamethrower to actually shoot
flames out in this world he does your
dragons already do that you're pulling a
fast one on me
cuphead technically that was like one
try cuz you didn't have your setup now
now grab matchstick don't turn it to
fire that's why I think special two is
great yeah I think the law is the best
for this one because it has the I think
it has the second highest damage that
after the church so yeah just one fact
oh thank you froggy for for like in the
video you're leaving though thank you
for hanging out see you later
so today we might not get to aisle three
which means you might not be able to
show the third secret boss but I will
say that the third secret boss is with
Sally stage play and it's it's quite the
doozy you definitely murder somebody
okay yeah we're gonna get that time we
got time
alright let's do let's do a running gun
okay let me just write it out let me
more just kind of not be angry no it's
good like find a good thing to kind of
even everything out yeah yeah yeah that
dragon fight went by very quick though
I'm not gonna lie eight hours of anger
and rage really mulch into fighting him
also I'm really excited to get off in
this island because I'm not gonna
promise a lot of uncomfortable things
going on these balloons with the eyes
and faces you know like they used to be
people don't tell me that that's some
Pokemon side story nonsense I'm not
trying to do them pass this vote I'm
just so used to doing it that way
music yeah I think that's by accident
too but I mean it's a good accident
yeah right what the hell out of their
work I can never do that one right you
know it's a it's a damage boost that
works by here alright this is fun look
at this guy he's so jazzed
he's look at these guys they're so
jazzed it's like a roll real melty
looking pretzel oh there's that broke
ketchup that came through
oh that's right cuz I got hit by the
guns hey there are some really rad like
fan animations of the boss fight oh yeah
there's people I I wish I knew their
actual Twitter or anything but they're
doing like a cup head man made a thing
like a boss battle song I saw it on
Twitter and it was pretty cool cuz so
that's fair what I'm trying to do is get
five all my cards just because it makes
the final area easy and you have to like
you can just use your disability and it
kind of walks on through but it means
finding the girl with pink pink balloon
with a face on it okay I actually might
like this a song the most yeah it's it's
a this is this is I mean I've gotten far
enough into know all the songs yet but
this this is Mario and I'm into it no
that's fine knowledge you have video
evidence of doing it I wish I didn't
have to hurt this guy but yeah here yeah
here have some magic spells
all right here we go snacks snacks are
here and watch out for rogue ketchup
sports again oh man
mustard relish forgot every relish might
be my least favorite condiment my Oh am
I the only one so I grew up in the
Midwest where you're not supposed to put
ketchup on anything so that's kind of
like my weird like I don't know any
better setup like you if you got like a
hot dog with ketchup on it you must mess
it up which is weird because it seems
like it's like the condiment yeah and
even I can notice that and recognize it
so fun fact my actually never had
mustard on hotdog or burger babysit oh
really
yeah cuz I just never I just thought it
looked frozen that's right nice yellow
but someone told me to try it and I was
like oh I've been doing this all wrong
oh man it provides such a good flavor
okay it's it's good I like it I'm hungry
damn it again again
whoops put just shapes and beeps shapes
and beats yes chips
I have plate and it is a very good time
um bird or B Evo reaction birdie birdie
just trying to push the the clown clown
business off just trying to not get
angry again yeah that's fair
[Music]
that's a big bird in a small house oh
wait until you see the little bird that
guy's crazy
heck yeah I'm just like wait a second
yeah there apparently a lot of people
who actually put like mayonnaise that's
a new one for me I don't know more of
like a look at like a chili dog kind of
person like a like a Sonic the Hedgehog
kind of thing relish and mustard are the
things that usually up if it wasn't like
a chili dog it'd be that or like it like
a Coney dog Coney dogs are great
should we just keep talking about lunch
I'm into it I mean I might not make this
I'm sorry you just got yep oh that's
right that's right yeah you Scout your
now first no I'm wondering if it's this
one earlier are watching Joey do this
one in the robot
all right seeing the the bird shoot out
the eggs just makes me think about banjo
kazooie oh maybe they had some influence
on me with banjo I just want one
one-pager to come back we all do in some
way - why I do a back flip we got a
banjo and smash I missed the music yeah
out of everything I truly miss the music
why are you here chilly tugs and sonic
or you got the sonic event I wish did
they have chili dogs there I assume
that's a weird thing chili dogs are only
a thing that cartoon sonic did not game
Sonic
movie Sonic is an anomaly at this point
we need to find more information on them
we must do investigated the bird and the
robot on expert Oh sounds like a not
good time I've never been more mad with
the robot the last round is just for me
anger inducing and I would not want
anyone to see we get mad well Edwin did
say it was this 100 why aren't you dead
yet sorry little guy
I don't mean that wish I do mean that at
the same time okay same in those does
this part yeah this is like oh that's me
every day when I wake up I turn into a
trash can I love it
I so I will say there's one thing about
the cup head on switch issue which I've
noticed before with this is that in the
last round when Oliver like things pop
up the frame rate slows down immensely
Oh which you know if you if you're you
know if you're the type of person well
this game really does need the frame
rate to be stellar - yeah you know make
things work but I've just noticed that
for that round that very last round a
little bit but that's just something
that I've noticed I don't know if you
guys have noticed it but let me know Jay
bogie says did they miss the secret boss
we've gone in debt we've done one song
and then we're on our way to the third
one right now yeah we're trying to get
to where I'm trying to beat this bird
guy and then the clown guy and then you
should have your third look at the
bosses the secret boss hopefully if not
then I'm sorry
and a game developer here are supposed
to be not here at the stream but a fee
to do another promo you do want to hear
the developers of cuphead talk about
their game check out the most recent
episode of audio logs yeah it's awesome
it's dared multi-county talks about the
king dice one of the coolest boss
battles that i've played in a very long
time so yeah I should definitely take
take a look at it that's that's here on
our youtube channel for you or on the
site or wherever you are and check it
out it's a good time you also check out
the one from last week where we talked
to Cory bar lon yeah like being on the
reverse and of it yeah yes I'm gonna do
BP before we sign off I will do BP
because nothing says let's party like
getting wrecked by a clown or excuse me
could strike get struck by home heck
yeah alright
I wouldn't see the dip ajiz just so
frustrating one of that Oh hard guy go
away
I can't believe that bird just through
its heart up it's Valentine's Day that's
cannibalism
jackaroo nice food all right let's do
baby yes yes great it's time to go it's
time to do it got a little over ten
minutes left on the stream okay well
we'll see where we get beeps well you're
gonna you're gonna one shot this and
it's gonna be super easy watch I'm ready
for it
I'm gonna see if I have my set up right
I didn't do one paddle Brian gun but you
know what what's whopper yes this one
yes this just needs to be different okay
oh they're so sad I'm not gonna help you
guys right now all right here we go the
carnival kerfuffle
fun fact they wanted to add a clown in
this game but didn't know how what what
moves or things he should have and the
main animator was like oh I got this so
blame Hannah for this because he did it
and damn he's not the guy this guy this
guy does not a drive where to get his
license like I know it seems like it's
not too bad at first and then it
definitely gets worse here we go this is
where it gets worse okay there I
remember this being like a fight that
people did not enjoy
there's so much happening okay okay okay
then this is the the real the real one
right this is how do you remember this s
remember the part where it turns into a
carousel this guy oh the care of cells
will worse part yeah okay it's fine this
is fine
oh no oh joy hard part about it is that
when you're on that thing and then that
shows up you have to kind of like doing
everything are you afraid of clowns not
afraid of clowns conscious make me feel
uncomfortable
do I want to join the circus if be bees
they're hard pass Atanas your stream was
a good time Tay Tay jumped on and did
some katana zero those are pretty quick
phase that wasn't bad
no it's only the Charlie first part that
makes that's a little bit difficult
I want to get this game my internet is
trapped and I got an Xbox zipper for ps4
get on PC or switch if you've got either
of those yeah that's true and you don't
eat Internet to play it oh why this is
so bad nice alright ok with a lot as
much damage is like you get it's all
just so much look at how these
superstars like yes this horse and heck
yes alright
oh no why why with this this needs to go
away now this needs to go away
now ok here we go well you know this is
the real fight step the real fight
happens now
yeah definitely Oh Oh God that's real
fast
that was really fast ok actually what am
i doing I need to do this this I was
doing it wrong I'm so sorry
oh gosh
[Music]
yeah yes [ __ ] wasn't even that bad what
about all my training years of training
and we've still got like eight minutes
oh really
yeah we did it I wonder if I can go I
don't do I have to do the run I've never
done this before
so I've kind of wanted cuz we did all
the bosses I just want to go through and
see if you guys will let us through and
then we can go to aisle three
heck yeah gotta go subscribe good luck
hey thanks for hanging out hope you have
a good rest of your day and I hope to
see you back hanging out with us yep did
it did don't cut that go sprint ins he's
on his way probably considering it for
the PC you can probably find a PC copy
of it pretty cheap too it goes on on
sale sometimes you know it'd be really
cool if the person who does does the
voice of King dice is the same person
who does okie boogie from Nightmare
Before Christmas oh man
[Music]
what this guy is a devil no everyone's
talking about Game of Thrones and I'm
just like I'm ready yeah yeah yeah all
right let's see we can beeline right to
the third boss right the all right cool
yeah let's do it
you know funny part is that you I wish
that you could just immediately go to
the secret secret but that's only if you
have the game completed really yeah
we're just doing it from the beginning
if you knock this one out pretty quick
we might be able to go a little bit
right it depends on if I do this
the animated cutscenes are is new
content yes a lot of they've provided a
lot of free content which are an updates
to things which is very very nice of
Studio mvhr it's super impressive makes
me want their DLC so much more
[Music]
where she come down from
[Music]
would be blue Drago says this is amazing
stream cuphead thank you who put on the
lap a good show Dania wants to know
where we're from
we're in San Francisco right now
gamespot headquarters hold down I prefer
the Lauber by the way everybody for this
one it just makes I feel like it makes
sense easier seems like the lovers just
a very good weapon is a very very good
weapon I met one help it's a very very
fantastic woman it's more like if you
don't have the charge but oh okay sorry
sorry
honoka's hang up she's now a plane the
the sound effect for the plane is that's
not McLean's dude they're trying to
trick me again and they can't trick me
so I try to do this so I can hit her a
lot faster and not worry about having a
dodge stuff whoa
okay I got right just punched it got
this yes sure awful I hope your I hope I
hope everything works out for you that's
that's no good works out well yeah
rough times are no fun focus and at the
same time yeah that's it's a heck of a
skill that not a lot of people think
about a lot be able to talk and play
games is not a natural thing spitting
out be missus yeah respect
I love creativeness we be who can do
more than just you know yeah yeah well
queen bees do I just realize all the
work desks that were inside of the
honeycombs
yeah the siren scene here oh no this is
bed area they all just got off of work
it's five o'clock we're going to bars or
relax a new good day nicely drink
puppets are fun though I will admit for
as bad as I am at the game I do enjoy it
what I do play
[Music]
Magic School Bus
oh man oh this is great heck yeah all
right you know what we got two minutes
left technically but I think we can
maybe go a little bit over for for at
least a run on yeah hopefully I can I
can get there I'm trying to see if
there's a shortcut that doesn't require
me attacking another boss
so we'll try okay fingers crossed
singing while playing guitar I feel like
that's in the like on a similar level
things that you you shouldn't be able to
do but it's amazing that you can do it
now try plain mod your guitar so every
single string is a movement or an attack
oh there you go that's the next week up
head with the Guitar Hero guitar I have
a friend back when I was streaming for
for Detroit where his whole thing was
just doing stupid stuff with games so
for one of his shows he beat an entire
arcade run of Marvel vs. Capcom 3 on
hard using only rock band drums so I
won't be able to do it I'd have to go
through
good guy so we're just gonna do one more
okay more soda will do the pirate guy
and then we'll just call it a day
sorry guys I really want to show you
guys Sally stage play cuz hers is the
most hilarious out of the three but
unfortunately we won't get to her we saw
two out of three of them and we had a
pretty good time in my opinion that it's
Angry radish and then Sally's dating
with all that port octopus it's not look
like they're having a good times thank
you oh you know it's good for this one
then I don't have that'll make this a
lot harder or longer is that the charge
though the charge is the best one for
this personally in my opinion I feel but
it just makes it go a lot faster
Oh what do you mike says you you're on
the back of the junkyard okay forty Mike
coming in clutch alright let's do this
once again it probably is fine no we
can't you know it you can all know that
was forty Mike that made us so we rented
the stream without being a pirate or do
you might know I trust for do you Mike I
all four dimensions I trust all four of
[Music]
alright you go around oh no not that way
junkyard uh right there there it is
forty Mike the God he's got it we did it
whoo I love you can't believe this
found all these these shortcuts 40 Mike
40 Mike the hero he did it he did it we
didn't do it he did it stream on the
record is dedicated to 40 Mike I hope he
saved this tree
perfect you saved it
Oh Omar also called it out to Omar
little bit later on but still call it
out okay so with this line oh darn I
didn't get it but so you have to like
get on these little cherub guys don't
you know obviously don't hurt her but
you want to use the little hearts that
she does so that you can jump up to jump
up on these guys you can attack her if
you want to but
she's got like a divekick got it so you
stay here and then that thing so you
hear the creek and then now you see that
it's kind of like oh there it is no I
was slow what is this
yikes
anyway we've still got like 7 min and we
have it 7 minutes - ok ok
Oh I mean how dim look oh yeah finally
works yeah we did it we had it and then
see here we go okay got it
perfect perfect I got it okay
[Music]
got it perfect and I will take that then
we killed him joint and she's
heartbroken and we did that directly to
the murderer
yeah I'd totally did a murder and I did
a murder this is when we get to the end
if I make it hopefully I hope I make it
because because though so what happens
is is that in the penultimate round
shoot in this so in the penultimate
round I might not make it so but he
turns into a god it's like a stop motion
god when she turns into a goddess but
he's for sure dead we've definitely
killed him okay
drop move again just buck up head hyper
dragons on on that Cup head business now
everyone's cheering yes this is part of
the play little did they know
yeah little do they know that you really
killed somebody
oh I'm sorry I might not get it but so
you still got five minutes
we got the ten minute extension third
time's the charm third real third time's
the charm
I can't let they cheer when he's dead
it's like a real like a mortal combat
fatality kind of situation Johnny yeah
well in the cockpit since yet
[Music]
fatalities will fatality for the fans Oh
almost had it and I oh look at him he's
so concerned for her no he didn't asked
for any of this and he ends up getting
the worst of it
oh why how do you show up
yikes yes the nuns are throwing no
they're throwing a ruler's oh they're
not throwing wooden crosses although
very poor sense yeah I think although
it's kind of funny that they throw
rulers it's like yeah don't hi this is a
bed yes over here perfect
please go she was ready for bed he's
edge there
oh you know what oh yeah it is a ruler
it's just spinning so fast that it looks
like it's a cross you're gonna say you
know what the hard part is gonna say
everything I'm just trying to get to the
penultimate round so people can see the
secret boss I'm just trying to do you
know a good thing oh there we go
okay we did it perfect everyone please
meet our dead God yeah you can hit both
of them well well look at it kind of
calls out what's what's coming in next
oh well I died but here you go that's it
we did it
yeah we can we could probably call it
there if you want okay yeah that's fine
all right
[Applause]
okay gotcha anyway that was a good time
a good time I had fun
yeah yeah I had fun a little puff head
is the worst thank you I've learned
anger rage uh I hope you guys had a lot
of fun too with us along the way and you
learned some cool things about secret
bosses and cuphead and a little bit
about ourselves you know yeah yeah again
we stream every single weekday at 11:00
a.m. Pacific all sorts of things you
don't want to miss it be sure to
subscribe to the channel check out the
latest episode of audio logs on cuphead
and the sine of king dice yeah one of
the coolest boss battles to date they go
see
and yeah thank you for tea Mike and
everybody for this suggestion because I
did not know and you know yeah we got
three and that's yeah I hope you guys
had a good time yeah
so yeah yeah anything else to you wanna
say before we head out now I have a good
week guys it's Monday you know enjoy
your week heck yeah yeah so don't be a
fool stay in school play
Jacques play dong and rapper way that
once he was very good
[Music]